في ظل المخاوف المستمره من تطبيق تيك توك
وامكانيه حظره بشكل تام انضمت النرويج الى
قائمه الدول التي حضرت استخدام التطبيق
على هواتف موظفها الرسميين لتلحق
بالولايات المتحده وبريطانيا في الخطوه
ذاتها
انكار مستمر من قبل الشركه حول المخاوف
المتداوله على الامن القومي الامريكي
فالرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك اكد ان التطبيق
لم ولن يشارك بيانات مستخدمه الامريكيين
مع الحكومه الصينيه وينتظر ان يدليا
بشهادته امام لجنه الطاقه والتجاره بمجلس
النواب الامريكي
شركه
لاي كيان حكومي او تخضع لسيطرته وليست
عميله للصين او لاي دوله اخرى
مظله الدول التي تتوجس مما يمكن ان يفعله
تيك توك تتسع لتصل الى حظر المنصه بشكل
تام في الكثير من الدول
وفق الحكومات وشركات الامن السيبراني فان
تيك توك قادر على الوصول الى البيانات
وجهه الاتصال والموقع الجغرافي وشبكات
الانترنت وبطاقه السم ايضا والخوف الاكبر
هو تسليم تلك المعلومات الى الحكومه
الصينيه من قبل شركه
للتطبيق رغم ان تيك توك يؤكد على ان
البيانات مخزنه خارج الصين وبالتحديد في
سنغافوره وامريكا مؤكدا انه لن يستجيب لاي
طلب حكوميا صيني بالحصول على المعلومات في
حال تقديمه الا ان ذلك لم يهدئ من روع
المنتقدين خاصه ان مقر الشركه الام هو في
الصين وعمر العربيه